how thoroughly has the bide
administration mismanaged american
leadership around the world well here's
one very significant indicator the saudi
kingdom saudi arabia reportedly
considering accepting chinese currency
instead of u.s dollars for its oil sales
to china this would be a huge change
for almost 50 years saudi arabia has
traded oil exclusively in u.s dollars
and that has been a massive boon to the
united states according to the wall
street journal which broke this story
the chinese government is quote offering
everything you could possibly imagine
to the saudis
what would this mean for the united
states elders colby is a former pentagon
official he's also a principal at the
marathon initiative we're happy to have
him join us tonight bridge thanks so
much for coming on so i we didn't want
to let the story pass i think it's being
ignored by a lot of people it seemed
like a like a major story to us is it
yeah i think so tucker and i think
you're right to point to the dollar's
role as central to our well-being in a
very practical level and i think what
we're seeing is early indications of a
movement towards probably two blocks
one led by us and one led by china and
that's going to have massive
implications especially if we're poorly
organized and i think the point that
you're making tucker which is absolutely
right is we need to be jealously and
carefully thinking about this kind of
crown jewel of the role of the dollar
and just being very careful in how we
use it and i mean the saudis are a great
example of of you know poor foresight
and strategic planning the
administration was very tough on the
saudis and yes the murder of jamal
khashoggi was an abomination but at the
other you know on the other hand if
you're going to end up needing them and
asking them for help maybe you should
think about how you you approach them in
the first place and this is not the only
example of that where where we need to
take strategic account of the
consequences and not be as you know
solely focused on
sort of moral posturing if you will and
that's and that's a classic example um
and because you know otherwise we're not
going to be thinking about what's in the
long-term interest the american people i
mean it feels like they're they're
college sophomores like all they're
capable of is a moral lecture and
they're you know i'm not against
moralizing we do it all the time there
are moral questions to solve but if
you're leading a country shouldn't you
put its interest at the top of your
concerns they don't seem to be
absolutely i think you do and i mean i
think you take proper account of the
ways in which you're going to uh you
know pursue sort of high-minded goals
and then you stick to them but if you're
going to make a huge moral issue and
then back off it when you need it well
that's going to result in a situation
which the saudis and the emiratis don't
return your phone call and that's not a
good situation that's not serving
anybody's interest not serving a moral
interest and it's not serving americans
interests that's exactly right we are a
force for good in the world because
we're rich okay because we can afford to
be burundi is not not because they're
not good people because they're not rich
like we are so if we jeopardize our
affluence we jeopardize our ability to
make the world better obviously
bridge colby i wish you a running state
department thank you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else